there you go easy hi there I'm Aria and
like many of you I am indoors and trying
to keep busy
so yesterday I posted a story on my
Instagram so tomorrow I'm at a little
bit of a mood to try and tackle a
histogram challenge for a video no idea
one thing so let me know down below if
there's an ice cream challenge you like
to see me try and the overwhelming
favorite was this so-called impossible
t-shirt handstand challenge that Tom
hall and started trending basically this
challenge is one where celebs and people
are doing a handstand up against the
wall while trying to put a t-shirt on so
I do have this wall here and I figure I
may as well distract myself from the
pile of other products I have going on
by spending the day upside down I think
this challenge is already quite
difficult but I think it'll be even more
difficult for me because even when I'm
training or going to the gym when it
comes to bodyweight exercises or
calisthenics
I'm absolutely terrible so there you
have it the blank canvas upon which my
artistry will unfold today my brother's
behind the camera by the way everyone
we're not bringing in randoms into the
home because what we're practicing
social distancing I've got my GoPro set
up here I'm gonna record it I'm a posted
online for gonna see I know there's
gonna take some time so I'm not gonna
make a plea to animal envy you guys
watch me shirtless the entire time so
I'll try it on with this first and then
if I feel like I'm getting a hang of it
take this off and do some shirtless
heavy breathing for everyone let's see
how this goes I'm gonna take you to my
office there's no like yeah another
first girl up be careful on your head
man
oh look you know push in more yeah well
that's what you guys do that yeah that
works that works okay that's part of
that you know don't forget Tom Holland
Jake Jill print a little man I'm
terrified that you know I was about I
know my goddamn head I got a concussion
I'll give you a quick breach my buddy
Jack who does a lot of training with me
and maybe he has some some idea of what
I could possibly do Oh
[Music]
have you seen this this this Tom haulin
a handstand t-shirt thing yeah yeah I'm
trying to do that I feel like it's
pretty easy this I get out of here for
you baby it's easy we got to put a
goddamn shirt on while you're doing it
yeah and you just like wiggle your arm
in I feel like most videos they're
pretty far yeah that's pretty good
no yeah just bring it closer what hands
light it closer to you the longer you
take the harder it's gonna get I know
slide it in and then with that hand just
kind of lift it up and then shake the
shirt up to like here whose world is
this don't wait around like once you get
it in both arms you just gotta start
shimmy in I'll let you go Jack I'll keep
trying
how long do you think this is gonna take
you to get
send myself the channel getting it done
today okay so I'm coming to learn is
that on top of the general difficulty of
pulling this off and the upper-body
strength or acquires the longer you do
it the harder it gets to so I guess the
scary thing is that the longer it takes
for me to pull this off the day the more
difficult it will be because the more
sore my muscles are going to get
throughout the day my arms right now
already started to burn a little bit
it's like I get a little bit of
successes I get an arm in I get another
arm in sometimes I get it close to
shimmying up my shoulder but then a
certain point just gets to be too
painful because I've been up there for
too long a big thank you to everyone
that suggested challenges for me to try
today especially those that suggested I
tried Tom Hall's handstand t-shirt
challenge which has so far only led to a
near concussion and the complete
smudging of my wall
it's not funny good as always that's it
I think I've just about got this so to
help me polish it off I've lined up a
call with a personal trainer who did
this on her Instagram to get any final
tips that she may have if you have the
upper-body strength
like you can do it but also having like
the range of motion of your shoulder
like your mobility and the shoulder lit
really has to be there too I'm able to
get my hands in the shirt but I can't
seem to get the shimmy over into my like
up I take my arm all the way through and
then I put it around my head and then
hold the other arm through okay but your
head doesn't go through yet so you don't
all the way through with one arm then
the other arm but then you stick your
head in last yeah unless you feel strong
enough to put it all the way around your
head and then finish the other arm
you have to like just commit to it right
away yeah okay put your hand down now
switch sides
I would I see that's where I would put
it on my head potentially yeah put your
head through put your head through good
put your hand right back down yeah there
you go got it got it oh you are right
there
yeah you can pretty sure her tip was
very helpful I think I could pull it off
now all right one more time
[Music]
this was a fun challenge to try it's a
bit daunting at first but I think once
you get it you get it overall I think
these challenges are fun can they kind
of pass the time we're all inside and
it's also just a great way to connect
with people around the world then who
knows maybe just show off your body if
you wanted to alright now that I've done
it I guess my challenge goes out to any
of you want to give it a shot
be sure to tag me if you do give it a
try stay safe if you do also just stay
inside wash your hands practice social
distancing and most importantly remember
that this is my world
this is this is what this is what
[Music]